[Musique]
qui a dit que l'humour n'a pas sa place
dans la lutte contre la désinformation
au delà de la vérification des faits et
de l'éducation aux médias l'humour peut
aussi faire partie de l'arsenal contre
ce phénomène sur le web et sur les ondes
d'ici première olivier niquet pratiquer
cet art avec brio depuis plusieurs
années ses cibles de prédilection les
radios d'opinion et les réseaux sociaux
l'unité bonjour bonjour très content que
ça se produise une rencontre qu'on a
longtemps souhaité et l'assassin
matérialise enfin tu avais tu as we
s'attendait à ce que vous méritiez avant
mais là ça serait si on est bien content
parce qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est que
au fil des ans dans tout ce que tu fais
surtout sur deux plateformes la
désinformation et présente jusqu'à 130
toile de fond des choses dont ils
traitent
les médias
comment ça c'est le produit comment à
des informations croisées dont je n'ai
que
ça fait partie un peu las personas la
désinformation début je m'intéressais à
cause qui exagéraient beaucoup mais
c'est une forme aussi des informations à
faire croire qu'une situation espère que
ce qu'elle est ça fait partie la
désinformation c'est ce qui
m'intéressait au départ qui au fil du
temps là j'ai vu est un polar seule
technique plus utiliser le sperme non
vax vaut en ce moment quatre fois plus
cher que le spectacle
c'est la réalité évidemment non ce polar
réalité que d'une fausse nouvelle un
vulgaire photo sha page d'une nouvelle
jérusalem pause partagé par les
conspirationnistes sur les réseaux
sociaux mais tout est dans la façon de
parler de la désinformation
qu'est-ce que tu gardes en tête quand tu
le fais parce que on le sait que c'est
délicat il faut pas mettre tout le monde
dans le même panier il faut pas
nécessairement ostraciser les certaines
personnes qui nous écoutent ben moi
c'est ça que je m'intéresse d'abord à ce
qui se dit dans les médias je
m'intéresse beaucoup moins aux
influenceurs conspirationnistes ça c'est
la première chose mais je sais aussi de
le faire avec humour parce que je pense
ce qu'on peut rejoindre plus de monde
avec s'attirer des gens par le mot mais
leurs passes et aussi de l'information
importante
on sait aux états unis de prendre un
certain temps là des émissions comme le
daily show reste la principale source
d'information d'une grande proportion de
jeunes américains n'ont que moi c'est de
façon un peu aussi cette année de livres
dans pas puis je veux qu'ils aient des
gens qui sont tétanisés ya encore des
gens qui veulent pouvoir leurs enfants à
présent si oui cela c'est le résultat du
canal niaisage
c'est le résultat des redifs le canal
niaiseuse j'imagine que c'est elle c'est
m bon c'est un peu misogyne mais on peut
sentir ndjock d'un enfant de 5 ans
pour des gens le réseau des imbéciles ou
la donne c'est gratuit je pense qu'aussi
quelques mots ça permet d'être moins
confrontant un peu parce que
plutôt que de répondre à quelqu'un que
c'est un handicap comment on peut lire
souvent sur les réseaux sociaux ben
ainslie répond par une blague déjà c'est
un peu moins confrontant juste de
montrer que ceux qui disent ça pas
vraiment dans le puits une façon d'un
peu de
montrer aux gens que ce genre de
discours existe
l'impasse pas vaccinale pour vendus dans
des commerces là c'est pas très
différent que de dire à quelqu'un les
blancs peuvent rentrer les noirs n'ont
regardé rappeler à vincenzo une
distinction ou une exclusion basé sur
autre chose qu'un motif interdit de
discriminations on aperçoit un règlement
c'est pour ça qu'à lui même interview au
monde de venir en test dans ses cinémas
ou d'apporter sa propre nourriture
[Musique]
qualifierais cette évolution là est ce
que pour un recadrage qui doit être fait
tout c'est très délicat parce qu'il est
question de liberté d'expression
mais comment tu vois ça ben moi c'est ce
que je suis absolument pas pour faire
taire ces personnes là je suis 100% pour
la liberté d'expression je pense que ça
passe plus par leur les propriétaires de
la station les les annonceurs aussi
qu'ils doivent faire plus sensibilisés
cela parce que c'est tout ça ça reste
une question d'argent parce que si un
matin là ils font ça pour le cache
d'abord parce que on est dans une
économie de l'attention fait que
d'autres pour attirer l'attention va
c'est un pl est de susciter la colère
des gens des deux camps comme je disais
puis métier mais juste assez
positif en général je suis un optimiste
et j'ai l'impression qu'on est dans une
phase temporaire où il faut s'adapter
aux nouvelles réalités des réseaux
sociaux ça change tout change très vite
jeu ça passe par l'éducation aussi dans
les écoles ce que tu fais d'ailleurs oui
moi je fais des conférences dans les
cégeps je parle à des gens qui sont ce
qu'ils sont super allumés qui sont
intéressés parce ce que je me rends
compte par contre c'est que eux ils
suivent pas du tout les médias
traditionnels ce serait d'un sondage
dans la salle à chaque fois savoir
combien parmi vous écoutent la radio il
y en a pas qu'ils la
suivent les réseaux sociaux les deux des
balades d'euros ce genre de truc là mais
moi je leur donne des exemples concrets
pour expliquer des mécanismes de la
désinformation pour chaque cas
est salutaire
dictature sanitaires ouais je sais que
tu as fait un segment qui est déjà pas
mal marché là dessus l'idée d'une
dictature sanitaire dans laquelle on se
trouve leur
dit il
on est en prêt de vélos totalitaires
sont vraiment pas commettre c'est quoi
une dictature pour dire ce genre de truc
là mais ça fait partie aussi la la
stratégie lorient nice il ya certes nyon
certains chronique en plus
intellectuel qui tient dans des concepts
un peu las pour eux pour les sanitaires
xmmd c1 et agressent nature sanitaire
utopie hygiéniste toutes ces affaires là
pour donner l'impression que sa [ __ ]
ea le monde dans lequel on vit moi je
convaincu en tant
qu'intellectuel que d'un vrai quentin et
montagny tarifs votre course aux séries
comme une des grandes utopies g fille
dans mes 30 ans vont se retrouver frère
votre ouïe très maniéré eux d'avoir un
jour penser que c'est important de se
laver les mains en sortant des toilettes
que la sexualité c'est plus sécuritaire
avec un cordon et que le poulet c'est
mieux puis tout ça ce qui me fascine
aussi c'est que souvent ils reçoivent
également donner de la visibilité à
certains leaders conspirationnistes et
en ont dit beaucoup de neige risquent
souvent ce qu'ils font c'est qu'une fois
qu'ils sont dénoncés sur la place
publique qui sont allés trop loin il
fasse rire et il est connu et retire les
contenus lévesque sera au tour de leurs
sites web comme si ça n'a jamais existé
donc ça c'est une stratégie que qui
utilisent régulièrement pour combien
temps quand tu vois suivre ce beat la
deûle écoute attentive des radios
d'opinion c'est une question que je me
pose chaque année mais je continue à
m'intéresser à ce puits on dirait que la
bâtisse est une ressource inépuisable
puissant enfants je pense que je encore
pour quelques quelques années